so today we're going to be learning how
to make a name plate or design a flame
plate using master cam so when you first
open the software this is the screen
that you will be seeing the name plate
is six inches by two and a half inches
by half an inch
create the nameplate using lines let's
start at zero zero and here this is the
length so let's put input the length of
six and we'll keep it horizontal so
there we go by
two and a half
which is so input 2.5 enter and we'll
click the vertical tab
you
and then again with the unclick the
vertical six and
we closed it off and we're good to go so
I like making the the image of the
nameplate prior so I can get an idea of
the area that I should be working in
so in mastercam you can create a bunch
of different lines line segments arcs
circles what we should first work on is
the outside the contour of the nameplate
now you can have a basic contour like a
basic square contour you can make a
ellipsoid contour or a circular contour
or pretty much any shape that you want
for me I'm just going to make a basic
ellipse so I'm going to select the base
point I want to start at the center
which is three inches in by 1.25 and
that as you can see in the circle here
and I will have this be
three inches
and the height be
so the ellipse barely touches the sides
of the nameplate and I want to make an
inner ellipse because I want to give the
surface another contour
we're going to create another ellipse
at the center so three enter 0.25
and this time we are going to go to two
point
9 and with and
1.15 and height
and as all so I'll make a basic
nameplate with the words name is Earl
and you can put it horizontally or
vertically or at the top or bottom of an
arc you can also put at the top of a
chain a chain is pretty much a line or a
closed line what I will do is I will
keep it horizontal also I will press
ENTER here try to put that in the center
and you can click the area that you want
it in now this is too big so what we
could do is press escape and we return
we undo and you can change the size and
the spacing of the lettering so what I
will do is change the size to 0.5 the
spacing changes automatically go back in
and there you go um let's back out
create letters check and adjust and
unfortunately master Kim there are some
things in master Kim that are not as
advanced that you actually have to go
back and it's pretty much trial and
error
now what you can do is also you can
create circles
um
lines as I said before
um you can create parallel lines so this
line and there we go
um you can create curves
there are splines and so on so you can
use these to create artwork if you want
so now let's say this is pretty much
you're pretty much done with creating
your basic nameplate what we want to
start doing now is creating the tool
paths so what we start with is the
contour
and we have to pick a chain as I said a
chain is a closed line so we'll click
this chain and I'll click OK now there
will be a set of tools that we will
assign you um it'll probably consist of
a an end mill a ball and mill an
engraving tool of some sort so we this
is the tool path when we open the tool
path we'll click on the contour the tool
you can select it from the library first
we'll select filter and we'll click on
the end mill and I'll click the ball and
mill era and click OK and we'll select
it from the tool library and here gives
us a list of flat end mills that we can
choose from now for this we can choose
the 1/4 or actually 1/2 flat end mill
and then we will do the cut parameters
so these are the cut parameters these
are pretty much options for how the tool
is going to cut the piece the
compensation the direction the depth of
the cut lead in and lead out how the
tool itself will enter the piece the
breakthrough if you're going to drill a
hole um how many passes you're going to
take to get to the final cut and the
linking parameters which are how the
tool itself is going to cut into the
piece how deep it's going to go so let's
start with depth cut we want to make the
max rough step which is how the how deep
the piece is going to go or how keep the
tool is going to go with every step
we'll make that a tenth of an inch with
a finishing step of half of that this is
the entry and exit we'll see how that
how enters and exits the piece
afterwards when we render it we won't be
breaking through we do not need only
path that's we'll go back and go
straight to the linking parameters we'll
click on the clearance and we'll say you
can choose to make the you know the tool
go back up to the clearance height which
is two inches above the piece only at
the beginning in the end of the
operation or if you do not click that
tab then you're going to make it go at
to it up to two inches whenever it's
done making a cut so this is the retract
that's after it's done making a cut it
goes up to 0.25 an inch above the piece
the feed plane is the feed rate we can
make that
point point point two is fine the top of
stock is at zero zero and the depth that
we want to go to is we said that the
piece the aluminum piece that you will
be working with the raw stock material
is 0.5 inches so we will make this 0.5
and that will be absolute check this and
it is now inside so this is the tool
path as you can see now from the top
view the tool path is inside the piece
that's not what we want we want it to be
from the outside so we will do is we
will click on parameters and we will go
to cut parameters and we'll let that be
right and check and this is the
regenerate button
you
and we regenerate that is what the
toolpath will look like so we can see
the tool the tool cutting to verify by
clicking this option and press play and
it will take a few paths and then it
will start cutting into the piece know
then
oh so in order for it to cut into the
piece what I forgot was to put the
negative sign here because we will be
cutting down into the negative Z
direction so again we will regenerate as
you can see it'll be more than one path
and we verify and there we are
can fast-forward
now we did go 0.5 into the into the
piece or 0.5 in the negative Z direction
but we didn't set the stock and
therefore mastercam generates stock for
us and we will set the stock later to
Andrey verify now that we're done doing
the outer contour I put an inner contour
a little chamfer or a little Phillip and
the way we do that is we create a new
tool path contour and we will select
this chain
click okay and the tool here will be the
ball end mil and we go to the tool
library and we will use a quarter inch
ball and mill so let me go straight to
linking parameters and we will select
depth of a tenth of an inch negative
direction and there we go we can verify
that by going up here regenerating and
play
now this will give us the entire two
paths both two paths
and we could fast-forward
and this is what I did with the ball and
mill so now it's time to do the
engraving there are several methods for
creating the engraving the best method
or the easiest method is to create a
basic contour again with an offset of
zero so it now is asking us to pick the
chains so we select all the change when
it says that pretty much you just have
to end the the contour chain that you're
at and just select the next one and
that's because it's asking for a branch
point and a branch points basically an
area where the line moves or or the line
ends and another one begins
so here the branch point was for this
line was this line so we can end that
there are no other branch points and in
this
you
all right
now again it's a contour we haven't
decided which tool we're we're going
which engraver we're going to use during
the semester so for now we're going to
use a 1/16 ball and mill on that and
we're going to set the diameter offset
to zero we will turn all compensation
off and we can go straight to linking
parameter and we'll say that the depth
is 1/2 tenth of an inch
so please ero five-
and that is all
now we can verify all this turn rate and
up here their file this
fast forward
um once and all you'll get funky things
like this so you'll go back and all you
have to do have to do is just change the
parameters here we left the lead in lead
out checked we uncheck that and I
believe the tool that we used was also
too large so we can reselect the tool
from the tool library
let's regenerate and let's see where
that gets us
fine
so whenever we find areas such as here
or here here that are incomplete that
means that they were not selected when
we were selecting the chains for the for
the tool to follow so all we have to do
we can actually turn off the tool path
so we can see better here and we just
wrestle echt them or we can create a new
tool path contour and I believe it was
the end of the a
the ii ii ii and
are and I believe that was it
again contour tool
the offsets are off lead-ins and these
outs are off you just reset this to 0.05
I give and we should be good to go now
let's see
we should actually
start from
here
and we can
it's forward okay so let's left is the
second side of the a the R
- path contour
we can actually also do is we can turn
on this contour
and see which areas have not been chosen
you can see over here hasn't been chosen
here and the bottom of the are so do
another tool path contour and there's
one
and here's one
and there
and here we are and that should be it
tools
compositions off leaving lis tails off
and the linking parameter again has to
be set and we are good to go
so
group generate and we couldn't watch it
so now it's making the contours
you
and there's my nameplate now you can do
an unlimited amount of designs on the
nameplate using the basic contour method
you also have different fonts that you
can choose from and in here as well
so you can also put it at the top of a
chain and make the the wording go around
the around or according to whichever
gene that you want so here can go inside
we can do it again create letters or
let's go back okay
um
create
letters and
contour and we will pick the opposite
direction this is for changing the
direction and it will be on the inside
as you can see ah let me turn these off
so that was my last one and you can
create a myriad of shapes and designs
using the options that you have here
and that is pretty much it it's very
basic very simple there's only two steps
left and these are to create to set up
the stock
pretty much just
and here is the
the box where you can sign up what you
do is you just set the dimensions which
as we said are two point five by six
point five and here you can choose where
the stock is held from so we will hold
it from this top portion here and that
will be our zeros and we will display it
and there you are that is stock
displayed we can we verify and we will
choose to go quickly and there it is
now what you can do is you can make your
ellipse a little bit small smaller than
the box itself so that you can make sure
that the tool passes over the entire
area so you do not have a flat surface
anywhere
and we can fast-forward through this and
there we are
that is you namely the final step is to
post process and that is pretty much
creating the code that we will use on
the machines and that will cover I will
do a quick post-processing right now and
firstly we have to set up the mill the
type of mill that we're using so here
the mill is default couple files and we
have to replace it with the type of mill
that we are using which is the friar MB
11 NLM 3000 and select okay and we will
post process all right all right
and here is the series of lines that
will come out
now we will save this to your desktop as
an EM file
to desktop and you can name it I'll name
it sample mean weight or okay small same
name and save it and we will go into our
desktop and there it is so you can open
this with a notepad
and there you are now we will be
assigning tool numbers so and the tool
types so these tool types we will be
telling you what what which they are and
their size their width and what number
to number them and that is all you'll
put this on the floppy to or you'll give
this to me on a flash drive I'll put on
a floppy disk and we will run it through
the machines I hope this was instructive
and thank you